[Música]
hola soy maría clara calle por natalia
cabrera esto es a qui américa el
programa donde revisaremos en
profundidad las historias y las noticias
de nuestro continente hoy hablaremos de
las elecciones presidenciales y
regionales en tres países
latinoamericanos en ecuador el nuevo
presidente llegará en medio de una aguda
polarización entre el candidato de
centroderecha y un heredero de rafael
correa aunque el exmandatario correa
sigue siendo influyente para inclinar la
balanza hacia la izquierda la segunda
vuelta dividió a los grupos indígenas
sobre si apoyar o no al candidato del
correcto en perú las elecciones
presidenciales y al congreso llegan en
medio de una crisis política y una gran
apatía de los ciudadanos están
escépticos ante la corrupción y el
empobrecimiento además ha habido juicios
políticos y renuncias en un país que ha
tenido cuatro presidentes en los últimos
cinco años bolivia es una historia
diferente porque los comicios son
regionales y únicamente en cuatro
departamentos en donde se convocó a una
segunda vuelta pero incluso así es una
determinante para medir el poder que
tiene en las ciudades principales el
oficialista movimiento al socialismo
luego de que reconquistó la presidencia
en noviembre pasado
comencemos entonces con ecuador- la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales es el vivo retrato de un
país dividido por un lado está el
izquierdista andrés araus heredando las
banderas de rafael correa y por el otro
está el ex banquero guillermo lasso
jalonando a los movimientos de
centroderecha aunque el expresidente
correa sigue siendo muy influyente en la
política ecuatoriana una de las grandes
novedades que mostraron estos comicios
fue la división del movimiento indígena
como lo explicamos en la siguiente nota
rafael correa no está en el tarjetón
pero su presencia se siente a través de
unos fijados políticos
andrés araus quien se consolida como la
nueva cara visible del correísmo en
ecuador con el las ideas del ex
presidente siguen vivas y
particularmente la revolución ciudadana
que impulsa correa durante más de una
década correa tuvo un poder electoral
enorme desde 2006 cuando fue elegido
presidente por primera vez luego los
ecuatorianos lo reeligieron en 2009 y en
2013 para los comicios de 2017 no se
presentó un cuerpo propio pero apoyó a
lady moreno su vicepresidente y mano
derecha sin embargo moreno se alejó giró
hacia el conservadurismo y se acercó al
fondo monetario internacional en esos
cuatro años desde la oposición
rafael correa enfrentó un juicio a la
distancia que en 2020 terminó con una
condena en su contra a ocho años de
cárcel por corrupción esto le trajo su
muerte política en el año en el que
aspiraba a ser candidato
vicepresidencial y ahora intenta
recuperar su influencia a través de
andré zarautz
gran diferencia es que los indígenas no
apoyan unificadamente al correísmo por
el fraude que denuncia a los candidatos
ya cooper es el líder indígena que no
llegó a la segunda vuelta presidencial
en respuesta la mayoría de grupos
étnicos decidió apoyar al voto nulo pero
no todos eligieron el mismo camino jaime
vargas presidente de la confederación
que agrupa a todas las asociaciones
aborígenes declaró su respaldo a rauch
pase lo que pase venga lo que venga
señora andrés araus economista
en apoyo de todas las nacionalidades de
la amazonía ecuatoriana por otro lado la
excandidata pierna cedeño antigua
fórmula a la vicepresidencia de ya q
pérez se inclinó por el ex banquero
guillermo lasso aunque sostiene que es
un voto en contra del correísmo me
dirijo estudio las 21 el movimiento
indígena pachakutik expulsó a vargas y
cedeño de sus filas así el nuevo
presidente de ecuador asumirá sin tener
el respaldo unificado de los movimientos
indígenas algo que ha sido muy común en
la última década ahora hablemos de perú
este es un caso bastante particular en
américa latina porque las elecciones
nacionales terminan con un ciclo
presidencial nunca antes visto en sólo
cinco años el país vio pasar a cuatro
presidentes el primero renunció al
segundo lo destituyeron el tercero duró
sólo cinco días en el poder y en su
reemplazo asumió el actual mandatario
que entregara el ejecutivo al candidato
ganador entre 18 competidores esta es la
historia de una crisis política sin
precedentes en perú
cuatro presidentes en cinco años esa es
la crisis política que podría superar
perú con las nuevas elecciones generales
la historia comienza con pedro pablo
kuczynski el candidato que fue elegido
en 2016 tras vencer a keiko fujimori
pero kuczynski no ganó las mayorías en
el legislativo y los fujimoristas se
quedaron con el control de las cámaras
esto jugó en contra del mandatario
cuando los congresistas le hicieron dos
juicios políticos acusándolo de
corrupción aunque kuczynski superó el
primer debate en el segundo prefirió
renunciar antes de que el legislativo
votará su posible destitución
esta confrontación política ha creado un
clima de ingobernabilidad el entonces
vicepresidente martín vizcarra reemplazó
al antiguo mandatario pero enfrentaba la
misma oposición de los legisladores
fujimoristas las tensiones reventaron en
septiembre de 2019 cuando vizcarra
disolvió el parlamento tan sólo unos
minutos antes de que los legisladores lo
suspendieran como presidente desde
choque de trenes terminó con una nueva
votación legislativa y vizcarra se quedó
en el poder pero el mandatario no cantó
victoria por mucho tiempo el nuevo
congreso impulsó un juicio político
contra el presidente por el escándalo de
un contratista sin experiencia vizcarra
se salvó de la emoción pero dos meses
después el congreso le hizo un segundo
juicio político por supuestas
acusaciones de soborno en su contra y
esta vez la mayoría de los congresistas
optaron por destituirlo
hoy día
el viejo palacio gobierno el ejecutivo
quedó en manos del entonces presidente
del congreso manuel merino pero de todos
fue el mandato más corto desde su
posición se realizaron las protestas más
grandes que ha habido en 20 años los
manifestantes consideraban injusta la
salida de vizcarra y veían a merino como
la representación de los tradicionales
partidos de centroderecha el punto de
quiebre fue la muerte de dos jóvenes
durante los choques con la policía esto
forzó a que el mismo congreso pidiera la
dimisión de manuel merino tan sólo cinco
días después de haberlo nombrado
presidente por último llegó francisco
sagasti con el objetivo de seguir en el
cargo hasta las elecciones del 11 de
abril para darle al país un poco de
estabilidad política en bolivia el
movimiento al socialismo es el gran
protagonista de las elecciones
regionales porque aunque se quedó con
las mayorías en la primera vuelta en
marzo no logró ganar en cuatro de las
principales gobernaciones del país pero
incluso así el partido político de evo
morales está
en auge después de haber perdido la
presidencia durante un año este es el
camino que ha recorrido el partido más
influyente de bolivia en la historia
reciente
el movimiento el socialismo ha hecho
campaña desde 1999
incluso en 2002 el líder cocalero evo
morales- se lanzó infructuosamente a la
presidencia un cargo que solo consiguió
a partir de 2006 cuando se convirtió en
el primer presidente indígena que tenía
el país en toda su historia
morales se nombra a sí mismo un
anticapitalista y un anti colonialista
en su gobierno volvió a bolivia a un
estado plurinacional que reconocía a
todos los pueblos indígenas y también
emprendió una campaña para hacer que las
petroleras y mineras quedaran en manos
del estado 123 medidas
nada más casi todas estas nacionalizados
médicas sin nada que menciona listas
morales se convirtió en un personaje
popular con el respaldo suficiente para
ser reelegido en 2009 y 2014 y lograr
que el movimiento al socialismo
consolidar a su poder durante más de 10
años pero la gloria no fue para siempre
en 2016 morales intentó cambiar la
constitución para aspirar a un cuarto
mandato consecutivo y perdió en las
urnas aunque prometió respetar la
decisión en 2019 se presentó por tercera
vez consecutiva a las elecciones
presidenciales y todo cambio morales
ganó por un margen tan estrecho que
debía haber una segunda votación y luego
el tribunal supremo electoral actualizó
los resultados sorpresivamente y le dio
la victoria la oposición denunció un
fraude organismos internacionales
sugirieron una nueva vuelta y las
protestas se encendieron sólo cuando los
policías se sumaron a los motines y
pidieron su renuncia pacífica evo
morales- de un paso al costado y se
exhibió en méxico y luego en argentina
en su reemplazo el congreso posicionó a
la entonces presidenta encargada del
senado jeanine áñez una conservadora
ultra católica el más recuperó el poder
en las elecciones presidenciales de
noviembre de 2020 con el ex ministro de
morales luis arce ahora en abril de este
año el partido se afianzó al quedarse
con 240 de las 336 alcaldías aunque
perdió las ciudades principales como la
paz cochabamba santa cruz y el alto un
revés que espero remediar con la segunda
vuelta de los comicios regionales en
cuatro de nueve departamentos
al igual que bolivia perú y ecuador
chile también estaba llamado a las urnas
el domingo 11 de abril a una de sus
elecciones más históricas de la última
década pero finalmente el senado pospuso
la votación en la que los chilenos
elegirían a las autoridades locales y en
los 155 constituyentes que redactarán la
próxima carta magna del país el congreso
aceptó la propuesta del presidente
sebastián piñera de mover las elecciones
hasta el 15 y el 16 de mayo ante el
repunte de contagios de kobe 19 es así
como la pandemia deja en vilo durante un
mes quienes serán los encargados de
escribir la nueva constitución chilena
ahora vamos al norte del continente el
presidente joe biden ya está dando
algunos de los giros que prometió en su
campaña presidencial sus primeros pasos
hacia el multilateralismo han marcado
una clara ruptura con la administración
de donald trump algunos ejemplos son la
reanudación de la ayuda económica a los
refugiados palestinos y la posibilidad
de regresar al pacto nuclear con irán
además eeuu ya volvió a la organización
mundial de la salud como lo explicamos
en el siguiente informe a watts quiero
decirles américa ha vuelto el
multilateralismo ha vuelto la diplomacia
a aguas y espert con estas palabras el
gobierno de bailén anunció la que sería
su guía para las relaciones
internacionales de eeuu
hoy casi cuatro meses después la
mandatario ha dado varios cambios
importantes el primero lo hizo a pocos
días de llegar a la casa blanca cuando
decidió que eeuu volviera a la
organización mundial de la salud
otras dos movidas hacia el
multilateralismo ocurrieron en los
últimos días
iniciar la asistencia económica para el
desarrollo y la seguridad humanitaria de
eeuu al pueblo palestino incluye 75
millones en asistencia económica y para
el desarrollo en cisjordania y gaza 10
millones para programas de consolidación
de la paz y 150 millones en asistencia
humanitaria para la agencia de obras
públicas y ayudas de la onu con esto
valencia aleja cada vez más de las
políticas de donald trump en cuyo
mandato de eeuu se afianzó como uno de
los mayores aliados de israel finalmente
la nueva administración de bailén ha
dicho estar dispuesta a negociar con
irán y con las cinco potencias que
firmaron el acuerdo en nuclear de 2015
aunque el gobierno de bailén todavía no
se ha comprometido a levantar las
sanciones contra los persas está
explorando la posibilidad de que eeuu
vuelva a suscribir el pacto del que
trump se retiró en 2018
y terminemos nuestro programa con la
imagen de la semana millones de
mariposas monarcas han encontrado un
santuario en mexico para salvarse de la
posible extinción y es que en los
últimos 20 años el 90% de esta especie
ya se extinguió en el mundo para
contrarrestar este proceso la reserva de
biósfera que está entre michoacán y el
estado de méxico recibe cada año a
millones de mariposas monarcas el sitio
es tan valioso que la unesco lo declaró
patrimonio de la humanidad en 2008
y así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa gracias por acompañarme en aquí
y américa recuerden que pueden seguirme
a través de las redes sociales que ven
en sus pantallas soy maría clara calle
por natalia cabrera
quédense conectados para más noticias
internacionales en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]